In this lesson, we're going to learn how you,
yes you, can in the comfort of your own
kitchen, extract raw DNA from living cells and see
it with the naked eye. DNA is a really,
really long naturally occurring molecule. In fact, you've
got over 6 feet of it packed into almost
every one of the cells in your body. How do you think that 6 feet of DNA fits
into a single cell? Could it be that DNA is long but really, really thin? Or
maybe it's highly organized by proteins. Or maybe
it's divided into more individual or mobile units
within a cell. Or maybe all the cells in your body have to expand to 6
feet in width. Go ahead and pick any and all answers that you think are best.